[Music]
one of the interesting byproducts of the
digitization of everything is the steep
rise in nostalgia for physicality
there's a great lecture from the writer
and publisher James bridle where he
laughs about the fact that nobody ever
really talked about the smell of books
until ebooks started to threaten their
existence all of a sudden we became
nostalgic for a quality that we never
really noticed before
or take the resurgence in vinyl record
sales while it's definitely true that
the sound quality of vinyl is amazing
I'd be willing to bet that our
attraction to it also has something to
do with the object itself a real thing
that takes up space in your home a
symbol of the analog world as more and
more of our lives get vacuumed into the
digital realm we're increasingly likely
I think to look for these symbols and be
attracted to them and the crazy thing is
that these reminders don't even have to
be physical objects all they have to do
to tap into that nostalgia is resemble
the traits of those objects think about
Instagram filters designed to look like
old cameras and film stocks these
filters mimic objects that most
Instagram users won't ever touch as
bridal says putting a filter on your
digital photo is an attempt to codify
that image as memory to wrap it up in
something solid and historical that
calls back to a time before everything
was fluid and changing and impossible to
hold on to in this way our nostalgia
becomes an aesthetic and in film one of
the features of that aesthetic is grain
film grain is a texture in processed
film that has the appearance of tiny
particles moving around randomly in the
image the amount of grain has to do with
the speed and size of the film stock and
the amount of light being used during
the arrow in film was the only choice
many photographers and filmmakers tried
hard to eliminate this aspect of film
processing but it was always a part of
cinema especially in low-budget
independent movies using smaller film
stocks like 16 millimeter and without
access to big professional
studio lighting these days it's easy to
tap into that indie aesthetic by using
grain the grain itself is loaded with
all these associations that reach back
into the history of film the question is
now that grain has its own aesthetic can
that aesthetic be pushed further and
that brings me to Mandy the second
feature film from Panos cosmatos if you
haven't seen it do that right now it
might still be playing at a local
theater near you Mandy is a revenge
horror movie starring Nicolas Cage
reminiscent of the grindhouse films of
the 70s and 80s when the movie is set
it's a simple story as most revenge
movies are but what sets it apart is the
psychoactive vision and focus of
cosmatos who clearly has something very
specific in mind visually movie is dark
grimy often saturated with primary
colors and completely awash in grain in
this way it's not unlike Kozma toeses
first feature beyond the black rainbow
which is much more ambiguous plot wise
but interested in exploring the same
visual fetishes for cosmatos it's not
just about paying homage to old films
it's about learning the expressive
potential of existing aesthetics and
stretching their qualities to see what
kinds of feelings and tones they can
evoke the way I look at it now though is
I feel like in the present time has no
meaning anymore yeah and so it's I feel
like now if choosing an era for your
film is almost like choosing a color
beyond the black rainbow and Mandy
invited us to consider film grain as a
visual tool like lighting or color not
just a byproduct of chemical processing
so what does green feel like maybe the
most prominent quality of film grain is
movement the grain is always moving it's
swimming which means that even in a
still life of let's say a flower on a
table that flower is alive even though
it's not moving Green gets inside
whatever's in the frame and imbues it
with motion in fact this kind of
swimming breathing movement from within
mimics the visual effects of
hallucinogenic drugs which play a major
part in Mandy film grain is hypnotic and
that adds to the sense of the film
existing in a dreamlike universe
or as one horribly bad acid trip at
times the grain almost has a paranoid
feeling like there's something squirming
under the image another quality of grain
is that it blends grain gives an
underlying texture to the frame so that
there is a continuity between one object
and another it gives the impression that
the image is atomized into tiny
particles that could disperse and
overlap cosmatos often mixes heavy grain
with smoke to heighten this effect for
the characters and the viewers nothing
is solid or what it seems things can
shift at a moment's notice in a world
that looks like this you're always
vulnerable always at risk of coming
apart the most striking example of this
is a scene in the first half of Mandy
where Mandy herself is kidnapped by a
cult and force-fed hallucinogenic drugs
cosmatos turns the dial way up on this
scene by drenching the image in purple
and pink hues and adding a trailing
effect to movement so that when the cult
leader Jeremiah sands gesticulates you
actually have this steam of grain that
falls away from the Christ Buddha spiked
then when he kneels down to speak to her
up close
cosmatos actually fades Mandy's face
into sands it's hardly noticeable at
first and that's purposeful the texture
of the image helps this be so subtle
that you're not quite sure if your mind
is playing tricks on you it's important
to note that even though this is cool as
hell and something that film geeks like
myself drool over this effect is not
just visual decoration it adds to the
story sans is trying to assimilate Mandy
into his cult as you see her face fade
into his he's using the qualities of
psychoactive drugs to loosen Mandy's
grip on her own identity so that he can
substitute his own stuff like this is
what gives Mandy its power its aesthetic
is not added on to the film after the
fact it's a film that literally wouldn't
function if you took those aesthetic
features away that's true for its use of
film grain and for all the other visual
fireworks of the movie you know as
history becomes nostalgia and nostalgia
becomes aesthetic a great opportunity is
being presented to new filmmakers I
agree with cosmatos time has no meaning
anymore every aesthetic of the past is a
palette for the future you can copy and
paste those old aesthetics onto your
work or you can take up the colors with
a spirit of experimentation and have
some fucking fun
[Music]
how you doing everybody thank you so
much for watching this episode was
brought to you by skill share an online
learning community for creators with
more than 18,000 classes and everything
from graphic design and film editing to
finance and IT security you know when I
learned Photoshop I learned it through a
mishmash of disconnected View Tube
videos and I can't help but feel that
the process would have gone a lot faster
if there was a class dedicated to
teaching me everything about that
program in a systematic way learning new
skills is super valuable to me because
whenever I learn a new skill it's like a
bunch of new ideas are suddenly unlocked
in my head I think what can I do with
this and that always always helps me
with writer's block a premium membership
begins around $10 a month for unlimited
access to all courses but the first 500
people to sign up using the link that's
right below in the description get their
first two months for free in those two
months you could easily learn the skills
you need to start a new hobby or
business more importantly the skills you
learn will help give you the ideas for
what that business or art project could
be definitely try it out thanks guys
I'll see you next time